[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so the moment
has come the Doctor Who 50th anniversary
episode just aired Time Lords of
Gallifrey Daleks of Skaro I served
notice on you all I also want to say big
thank you to BBC America for putting on
the livestream and inviting me it was so
much fun so there are so many things we
can talk about so I'm gonna be doing a
couple videos for the 50th anniversary
this video will be my top 5 moments in
my initial review I'll be doing a
separate video for Easter eggs as well
as a video for the Christmas special and
series 8 be sure to subscribe to get
them so let's do this top five moments
number five the time war so classic who
as well as some of the modern
incarnations have shown Gallifrey and
the Time Lords but never at this level
of detail learning all about the Time
Vault and the forbidden weapons was
amazing as well as seeing the Council of
generals as well as the destruction
during the time war you get a really
good sense for just how bad things had
gotten for the Time Lords when they say
we've used all the forbidden weapons
with the exception of the moment
obviously number four at the moment so
the moment is the most powerful weapons
the Time Lords ever created it was so
powerful that it gained sentience and
developed a conscience that conscience
is played by Billy Piper we kind of
thought she was playing bad wolf but she
was just appearing in bad wolf form her
character is important for a number of
reasons mostly because it allowed them
to bend the logic of time and space
around that day that last day of the
time war
so John Hurt's doctor would not have
been able to get out of that moment in
time and David Tennant and Matt Smith
would not have been able to get in
Halley Piper also serves as John Hurt's
conscience for most of the episode until
Clara kind of takes over in that final
moment you can think of the episode is
like a Christmas Carol John Hurt's
character is Scrooge and the ghosts of
past present and future is Billy Piper
he even says at the end of the episode
she showed me the future that I needed
to see which is basically what happens
in A Christmas Carol number three all
the doctors together at the same time so
you could cut an alternate version of
this episode there's just the doctors
talking to each other the wordplay was
so funny in the synchronous way in which
Matt Smith and David Tennant kind of
moved together was hilarious on a
technical level all these doctors are
the same person but because of the
experiences each one has had there are
really different people number two
rewriting Doctor Who history so
obviously the solution to the problem
basically rewrites all of the doctors
history the thing is is that most of
them won't even know that it happened
especially John Hurt's Doctor
he's still gonna go on to be that very
regretful guilt-ridden 9th doctor that
Christopher Eccleston was obviously the
end Matt Smith gets to cheat just a
little bit with the help from a very
surprised cameo from Tom Baker which was
just an amazing moment all by itself but
now that kind of informs where series 8
is going so it was an amazing moment for
a number of reasons because now series 8
is basically gonna be the search for
Gallifrey I'll talk more about series 8
and what Capaldi is going to be doing as
well as that quest for Gallifrey in that
series a video that I'm doing later
today but that final moment when they're
all together on screen together all 13
doctors was just so amazing is this big
crescendo in the action so already it
was amazing because of the three doctors
positioning themselves around Gallifrey
and then all of a sudden all 13 doctors
are all showing up it's done with a
little help from computer graphics but
obviously seeing them all together at
the same time and then seeing Capaldi's
eyes flash on the screen in that final
moment was just so epic and my number
one moment Peter Capaldi's cameo so
obviously it was so brief and I honestly
kind of thought that Capaldi was gonna
be that curator at the end of the
episode I didn't think I was gonna be
Tom Baker but have you said the emotion
on Capaldi's eyes it was very different
from the emotions of the other doctors
the other doctors were actually very
hopeful and very happy about this
solution that they were enacting
Capaldi's doctor actually looked really
pissed off so I'm guessing that the tone
of his run on Doctor Who
capaldis 12th doctor it's gonna be a
much angrier doctor I was a little
disappointed that we didn't get to see
his costume but obviously that's a trump
card that Steven Moffat is holding for
the Christmas special like I said there
are so many Easter eggs in this we could
talk about it all day I'm gonna be doing
my Easter Egg video for the 50th
anniversary next week be sure to
subscribe to get it
later tonight I'll be posting a review
of that teaser for the Christmas special
as well as some thoughts about series 8
and where the show is headed next year
be sure to write your own top five
moments in the comments below but
overall I love this episode so much
honestly I don't think there was
anything that could have happened that
would have made me not love it it is my
new favorite episode of Doctor Who of
all time to be fair I did know what the
episode was going to be about I knew it
was going to be about the time war and
that last day going into it but I was
really surprised by one the solution to
the problem and how they changed Doctor
Who history and to kind of the roles of
the supporting characters so not only do
I give this an A+ for the style the
music was amazing too they changed the
Doctor Who theme just a little bit the I
am the doctor theme the story was
amazing
they used David Tennant in the best
possible way John Hurt was amazing
all the other actors were great mara was
amazing as the conscience she was really
the one that gave them their solution at
the end well what do we do
you do what you always done you be a
doctor I was so surprised by how overtly
they kind of showed us what series 8 is
going to be about this search for
Gallifrey and I'm so interested to find
out how that's going to change Doctor
Who going forward because that gives the
story so many places to go in serious 8
9 10 and going forward in my mind the
real theme of the episode though is the
redemption of John Hurt's doctor it's
not so much about what he did to stop
the time war it's about what he did not
do like that final moment when they all
had their hand on the button I honestly
thought they were gonna press it no more
was also a huge theme see if you could
write below in the comments how many
times was no more shown on screen and
uttered by a character so all that being
said I'll be watching it 5 more times
today you can click here to get that
series 8 and Christmas special video
that I'll be posting later tonight and
click here to learn about my top 5
favorite doctors of all time thank you
so much for watching high fives I'll see
you guys tonight
Gallifrey Falls no more
you